you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on HS org and
I'm playing a 15-2 game against chess
good okay let's go with d5 see what we
get by white maybe a cattle in the night
of 3 e 6 sometimes when this pawn is on
hmm okay I was gonna say with d4
sometimes it's better to first play mmm
c5 prior to Bishop moving and the events
of a capture you could recapture in one
move but okay white is going with d3 so
maybe some Kings Indian attack setup
okay well I think this is a good start
I could even consider playing a 5 but I
think with such an early d3 they're
pretty much going to allow block to set
up a pawn trio so I don't think that
there's any rush with e v c6 a c5 knight
c6 and then e5 I think is a good
approach let's get that C pawn
contributing and then tuck the knight in
right behind him and then go from there
okay that's slightly mysterious to see
Knight c3 hmm okay well it stays clear
the dark square bishop that's true but
white does run the risk of some advance
with tempo space gain or move alright
I don't see any reason not to just
develop here I don't think it's
worthwhile to give this night at kick
right away mm-hm yeah that's just about
how they're gonna play e5 okay Ari for I
should say yes so on e4 I guess Knight
to e2 and then the game will turn hmm
it'll be played in a way where I play on
the Queen side because I'll have a space
advantage on the Queen side and then
white will be going for this natural F
for that we'll need some prep work
however d4 have to be a bit careful of a
too early a move f4 because of Knight g4
maybe into e3 but first things first
d5 is hit three times I don't think I
gain anything by capturing so let's grab
some space let's see where the night
goes will he go into d5 no all right
well I'm pretty sure this is the follow
up yeah let's go pawn in the center
fourth ranked space advantage not quite
sure where the dark square bishop
belongs hmm I was mentioning that maybe
this move was needed prior to a4 because
of Knight g4 can i really take advantage
of this square it is a hole in the white
position I already have pawn support for
it I'd really like to have dark square
Bishop sixth and then throw my knight in
here via beast hmm
well I'm leaning more towards Bishop
here anticipating pressure against a
five tonight we'll be going here soon
enough
remove is there to consider you know I
think
this is a very important square e five
because I'm not going to be able to
maintain upon here
I can't move my have fun so it's
important that I maintain control over a
five with the piece so let's get him
here and the reason for this is so that
make sure we keep this light square
bishop under control this pawn is
allowed to move then you have to contend
with this Bishop okay I wonder if I
could play Knight g4 right now hmm
Knight g4 h3 I throw my knight in there
I don't know quite sure this is
something that I think will happen soon
Knight f4 into d5 I want to stay clear
of capturing an f4 and you know for as
long as this tension remains I have to
be a little bit concerned about maybe
white pushing grabbing some kingside
space and then squeezing me on the Kings
side
I was thinking for a moment about Bishop
g4 but I don't know if I'm so willing to
give up my light square bishop hmm Queen
c7 maybe maybe Queen c7 yeah let's go
with Queen c7 still just not sure I'm
gonna have to make another move because
I'm pretty sure they're gonna go with
the natural development or the castling
so okay I Castle I'm actually really a
bit nervous of this f5 push hmm if I
play Knight h5 what are they going to do
a knight h5 they'll probably take and
then just jump the knight in here also
now it's my queen on c7 this night when
it hits here to be with tempo if I don't
have a piece that could immediately take
it out maybe I could consider Bishop g4
and on h3 Bishop to d7 hmm or you know
what maybe first h6 I'm a I'm a I think
I'm looking to Castle queenside actually
and I kind of make a waiting move not
I'm not so sure here I wonder if I could
have approached the opening phase just a
little bit different it feels a little
bit uncomfortable and quite natural for
right now it's easy play I'm working
with a space advantage but no no they're
gonna have play for the rook in just a
blink so we'll see I I want to I think I
should stay away from capturing enough
for so and how are they to move forward
I think eventually they just have to
commit okay that's a very very big
decision a very very big decision so
they close the center well they release
the tension on e5 so they're looking to
come at me on the Kings side so
fortunately a my king is not there and
this move now is quite quite useful
because this is the direction they go in
and for 1g5 hits at least I can say my
rook hon H will play so let's get
rolling here I believe Bishop d7
queenside castle I don't think that it's
worthwhile to invest the time with b6
Bishop b7 I think just go with a quick
Bishop d7 and queenside castle in the
meantime this is the next pawn move I
have to be on the lookout for these two
moves ok a3 a3 really doesn't scare me
because I have this covered so much ok
wait would me it may be the case that
they play a c4 let's I'm pretty sure I
know where my King belongs now they may
play c4 and maybe I don't take maybe I
actually do something like this rook to
b8 and then look for a b5 break King
being on a8 this bishops eyes might
start to widen some some tactical
opportunities so ok this is a big moment
again my rook is opposite their queen
are there any tricks hmm
I don't think cat capturing is a good
idea this night is going to reroute to
c4 let's start with this and see if they
take on d4 maybe that's their idea to
take on d4 and then play b4 opposite
sides castling time will be a big factor
time on chessboard itself in probably
another clock so on takes a my welcome
to one piece exchange I'm playing with a
space advantage normally shy away from
that but maybe I'm okay with it
alright let's get some faster moves in
here let's start with Queen b6 and place
c4 wait a second this is a big moment
you know this is a very big moment I
think I need to be very accurate here I
think I play c4 c4 takes on takes pacman
node c4 pawn takes I can consider a push
and then maybe takes here
I can't calculate it all but I think I'm
going to roll the dice some at least my
king is off this file for for winner of
the C file opens up and maybe I could
take advantage of the fact that the king
is still on this open diagonal maybe my
bishop our queen without my pawn on c5
can make use of that Kings position so
let's let's open stuff up it's only a
slight development lead that I have here
and I like this c4 move I believe in
large part because after this bishop
move it masks
Queen so this point is a bit sensitive
so let's see yeah that's this bishop
here or queen here at some stage I don't
know if I would want to go pawn hunting
I don't want to see this pawn I want to
keep the beep on White's be pawn on
board no you know otherwise I'm dealing
with some file pressure against my king
so what am i doing on takes suppose D
takes see what I take here or push I
don't know
I'm not quite sure I may end up losing a
pawn but I could maybe grab the bishop
hair maybe take advantage of this Queen
being opposite my rook it's one of these
uh you know intuitive moves King I can't
calculate it at all but uh yeah just
kind of weighing the pros and cons this
was clearly factoring into my decision
here I'm not quite sure how I could make
use of it or if but we'll see suppose C
takes D I'm taking here I think they
have yeah they have to do that okay so
now what
t3 yeah you know what I'm gonna play d3
yep let's go for it
d3 Bishop c5 Knight at Knight g4 that
could really start to be a pain though
hmm
this Knight and he only has one square
so I'm not sure what the delay is a
knight here if I do a check King in the
corner Knight g4 Knight takes pawn that
covers up two so there is no fork
however if I take the pawn in Knight
takes here I could take the bishop and
if Queen takes I push with a fork so a
knight takes pawn Knight takes pawn
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes would
be the move hmm
I could also consider taking the pond
and then not taking the bishop but
instead retreating my knight preparing
me for I'm a bit hesitant to start with
this because when the knight takes he's
going to be striking at my bishop hmm
well I think I need to grab this guy
let's do that you know let's see are
they gonna do something like this my
knight is unprotected on e4 it's turned
quite tactical I'm sure there will be an
improvement in the opening for me at
least
let's see he takes t3 not sure what
there is what else there is to consider
here for a white okay they aren't going
for that so they're trying to take
advantage of my night being unprotected
okay so in other words if I take the
bishop they're going to do what exactly
mmm I think they just blundered yeah
they just blundered you see the move
here if I take the knight they just take
this Knight back but I could give this
check and after the King moves I could
take with the Queen I'm defending the
knight they could pile up on it but I
could also take here and defend it hmm
is there something else I mean the other
thing is actually Bishop c5 and Knight
up to right away this must be right
let's give it a shot in the corner oh
you know what if the rook plays here to
try and pin I could just move the knight
into f2 or is there idea after Queen
takes Knight Knight here hitting two
pieces hmm I take the bishop they take
one of these two with check and then
recapture
let's see oh I can't take the night be a
pin oh okay
glad I spotted that okay well I'm down
upon but I have a passed pawn I'm
leaning now more towards Knight takes
bishop yeah I think I need to go with
that
I'd have to Rick takes Bishop takes and
this here is gonna get some material
back I believe so let's get rid of that
taking with the rook and I don't want to
allow this pawn to be captured so easily
the knight here is crying out to be
played yeah let's do it
Knight g4 and they take c4 hitting the
Queen I'm defending this pawn they might
try something like be 400 I'll scoop
that pawn up hit the Queen and then I
could retreat and Knight takes b4 if I'm
just well let's say on b4 if I retreat
the door gets slammed and my bishop with
c5 were they going to do about this they
take c4 pretty strong with tempo where
does this ripple long move let's see
that I think I need to undermine that
Bishop it's too strong huh
okay hmm that's an interesting move huh
to have to play Knight g4 into e3 and
get the bishop that way well let's try
it
Wow yeah I'd totally overlooked that
Bishop to d5 move connecting uh you know
focusing on this intersection Square
that's c4 pawn yeah I got to remove him
you know their King has vomited the more
vulnerable of the two so even if I'm
down material and currently I am down
one pond
soon to be two but I believe I'll be
getting one back and there's still some
potential issue for white tactically the
rookies still opposite the Queen their
King is exposed and all the more
vulnerable without their light-square
bishop so I haven't been very good at
predicting my opponent's moves up into
this point so how to be on my toes
Knight to e3 hmm suppose rook here could
be strong yeah that could be real strong
I wonder if maybe b5 then I have this
move as well he's talking about night
here but what about Bishop here at some
stage maybe even Queen takes pawn no
Queen takes pawn Knight up to
you know even in situations like that
they can maybe give up the exchange and
they have a at least two pawns for it
alrighty
I'm before what would I do before Queen
here Queen takes pawn and then I have
this it's good to know but he's a
monster mmm okay okay I think I got to
make a move soon they're gonna take my
bishop Queen takes mm-hmm I don't think
I have anything here okay um let's try
this I may end up in a pin actually yeah
I may have just blundered here with
Knight takes Bishop Queen takes Queen F
- I think I'm in very rough shape then
what
I'm just getting a message here that
says the other player may have left the
game you can claim victory call the game
of draw or wait what a moment I'm gonna
wait I had my moment I could have
claimed victory well what a what a great
feeling it would have been - right
that was my last chance to maybe win
this game claim victory yeah I think I'm
I think I'm busted here Knight takes
Bishop Queen takes because this
another in-between move with Chuck yeah
so now how am I getting out of this pin
well maybe I have a sneaky move you know
cuz I am on the rook still you can't go
here if Queen F - I believe Queen here
threatening Knight takes rook and if the
rook moves I have Knight takes Bishop
hitting the Queen who's unprotected and
if Queen takes Queen I take this take
the Queen with my knight if all that I
think I'm getting the pawn back we're
gonna see rook here maybe pretty natural
I'd like to keep the Queen's on the
board they have the more vulnerable King
so if Rick here I'm going to take and
then take with the rook they have a
check that's not fun I'll have to go
here I'll still need a flight square
this will be the flight square that I
try to get in what they do an
in-betweener before I could take the
rook because I'm on their queen we'll
see hmm Knight takes here I don't know
about that I have to be careful I have a
in exposed King as well five minutes
with that thought you might do that I
think I have to do this so now if the
rook moves it's a blunder so I think I'm
getting the exchange now also the night
when it takes here it covers up for
maybe they're going to give that check
first mm I guess then King in the corner
and then finally maybe I could get rid
of this pesky minor piece good grief
what a pain
they could easily blunder here Brooke
here and takes bishop so I think I'm
going to get the exchange so we'll be
playing with that imbalance we need a
four check King here yeah let's do it
man you got 17 seconds okay yeah I'd
still need that flight square can't go
here covering this I mean that I'm in a
pin here so if some point this pawn has
pressure on it I might have to be
careful I don't see how I get rid of
this Bishop might have to work around
him focus on the e-file hmm yeah I think
that's the Avenue that's the approach to
take if we enter this imbalance the me
having the rook and then having the
bishop in two pawns
yeah that's what it is
so some other move that I'm missing here
my rook is unprotected I don't see how
could be attacked here I think are they
going to allow me to take the rook or
are they going to play here and yeah
okay
so let's take that guy out okay back
rank I have covered for the moment also
now that that light-square bishop is
gone maybe I could think about occupying
it with my queen they're really quick to
challenge my rook I'm on the v2 pawn hmm
I might take it yeah I might grab that
pond so rook here I might I might go
ahead and grab that b2 pond why not
actually for the moment my back rank is
covered if they threaten me then I could
do that
in the middle game position I was more
hesitant to maybe grab that beep on but
in this heavy piece ending it's a much
different story okay I could do this
wing takes rook takes I could return
here I have control over d8 also this
prevents the rook from entering and very
soon I hope to get this a6 move in it's
making me nervous not having a flight
square for Viking must be said so
they're still not playing without their
rook they're at about the two-minute
mark who's gonna slip if the Queen
leaves this dog and I'll Queen c6 should
be pretty strong and if Queen here I
could consider this nope because
actually I could go in c6 here no longer
has pressure on this I want that flight
Square and really soon hmm
I'd also consider getting to this second
rank uh-huh it's time for a flights
crown feeling better now much better
I don't can I take that pawn rook b1 and
then c4 hmm probably do something else I
don't know if I want to take that beep
on how about Queen here looking to pick
up a pawn Wow
okay I was too close
also not quite sure what I'm doing with
this move hmm they're gonna play b5 to
close it up c4 I go here working with 4
seconds time is catching up though
already I mean if these pawns get too
close to my king I may be the one who's
trying to get the Queen's off the board
yeah got to keep that closed maybe sneak
my king up Queens off the board my king
could be really strong let's say on the
c5 square to be careful of this pawn in
advance well let's hit the Queen hitting
c4 put in there huh all right well
here's the plan get your king up really
soon and then get your rooks to the
second rank I'm doing this so they don't
have this move okay I think they're in
trouble I have at least a draw there are
ten seconds now let's rook here
perpetual oh they have that move I got
to hunt him down yeah I got a hunt this
pawn down hmm okay
he had to be careful they were ready to
get to the second my second I'm
threatening mate mmm
no already could you take this pawn and
defend B oh man I think they missed that
I have B the beep uncovered now I got
the pigs first strike they just fell for
me they had to go to the corner hole man
that was an ugly game hmm
that was really ugly yeah
all right good game let me go back to
this I don't think I played the opening
well yeah no no this that efore move
came too easily and the play was uh I
don't know it just seemed too easy for a
white playing with f4 Knight f3 you open
that file and I think there may be too
quick to push f5 let me just put it on
the board here you know I know maybe
it'll be saying even ish yeah okay it's
even inch but I don't know this is an
uncomfortable moment for me I don't like
playing h6 where's the graph saying well
it's fine I guess I had something good
here huh I take C 5 is a blunder but I
did not take advantage of it Bishop
check and it's what is it saying so move
up let me put the arrows on here here we
go
Queen to b6 minus 2 what am I missing
here Knight takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight and then Bishop here
okay yeah
so I could play this position with still
two minor pieces on the board
the Queen's still on board and against
their open King this pawn is tough to
hunt down in the how it played out
they got this pawn right back and that
heavy piece ending yeah said I I could
have done better but keeping some pieces
on the board is maybe one of the ideas
behind going for this variation here I
was maybe too fixated on just not
capturing this knight anymore
Bishop here but taking allowing the
knight to just be taken back and then
get rid of his most White's most
valuable minor piece just light square
bishop okay yeah this is big trouble now
well that's the other idea just to scoop
up that C pawn this would have been much
more clean huh much more clean that's
not even the right thing
right thing to say hmm
okay well when things did get tactical
cuz I like that c4 move the King here oh
okay
well I'm happy about this this is maybe
the only thing I'm happy about is that
this is a the right idea here the c-4
move but let me just look at the opening
a bit more it's a really any issue with
Lang c5 and I guess this is okay
bishop they're reinforced e5 that's the
most important square in c7 wants to
take em you see this is where I would
not be so quick to trust the computer
with this castles and this isn't just be
this isn't just like oh don't trust the
engine here you know stockfish is more
reliable type I could even see like
stock finisher you know like a really
strong engine suggesting this and maybe
it's defendable you know against this
possibility of f5 and then g5 but
computer could not accurately assess
that at this type of a closed physician
so yeah I'd hold off on castling
kingside
that's why I went with a more flexible
Queen c7 I'm not quite sure where my
bishop belongs and I thought why not go
here to reinforce 'if I've some more I
guess it's fine doesn't like h3 who
wants to go with castles again there it
doesn't like h6 it's not bad but they're
okay it does not like this closing up
idea it still wants to go Kings side
it's just not happening Bishop d7 no I'm
not going Kings side this is too much I
don't know like just to maybe highlight
if I'm going Kings side this is what I'm
fearful of g4 I go here and look what's
happening over here actually I don't
even know if you know I'm leaning more
towards like I don't know I was thinking
for a moment about h4 and then g5 but
okay let's just go with the g5 right
away this is a bit scary no my king here
rook g1 it seems like a pretty dangerous
attack and I'm constantly having to work
around this this pawn that has great
depth space advantage that White House
and I know yeah it's saying negative 0.5
but that's too scary no I don't think
it's steer clear of that stay clear of
these positions it's just too much to
deal with so I had it in my mind to
Castle queenside because of this idea so
what could white have done better
instead of pushing they should maintain
this tension keep me guessing somewhere
c3 they did call c3 so they should do it
right now and still keep this tension
keep me guessing capture push we don't
know I don't know so ok they pushed
right away White Queen side Bishop d2
they want to take first and then play b5
yep
that's a better approach for white but
instead they played Bishop d2 and this
gave me a moment to play c4 and that's
tough you know what takes and now
there's an advantage here with d3 the
other option to take here I'm taking
here I'm out of Knight taking the rook
yeah and again this this diagonal will
factor in some home so I went with d3 I
might takes so what the [ __ ] they should
have a guard at this diagonal mmm I had
my moment here to find the winning
continuation I didn't and come up with
it and I took their man why didn't I
just take that night I'm even on this
pawn here silly so that throws away the
advantage again I could take here they
take there and here he still lives in
there robbed of their most valuable
minor piece well maybe just call it the
most valuable piece the most important
piece he's the best defender for their
vulnerable King
that's and that's as far as I had to
take it I don't have to calculate any
deeper it's just understanding that
position that resulting position takes
and then this is my opportunity to
exchange light square bishop s-- that's
it's the only thing that i really had to
look into right I only had a view view
it like that and that would have been
sufficient for me to go with that
variation I wouldn't have had to
calculate anything further okay that's
what I want with this now it's even 95
bishop they're strong it doesn't like
Knight g4 yeah this is where light now
starts to be the better side by a pond
almost two points the best part mm-hmm
okay with Knight g4 what is it let's go
with this and on this move who we have
this getting the night okay
then one night g4 93 takes takes Queen
f2 strong move Queen b6 yeah if they're
moving the rook this is what I was
pointing out I get to take on Queen
takes there's this so they saw that got
off at this diagonal they gave a check
oh so focused on just getting that
Bishop out here I have a fork on c2 mr.
Otto tactics and I think towards the end
here I could have done something a bit
better
85 okay still pretty even no though they
have a pawn advantage you have to be a
bit careful because of this structure
you know King safety for as long as the
boats rooks still remain on board it's
still tactical one rook its technical I
know I'm officially lost
this this phone is too dangerous second
yeah you know I think I was really close
to the loosing on time right around here
if I just go with the doubling they take
the pond and they're defending the only
threat I have here so yeah but with this
and then here I want to keep this guy
here in case the rook leaves to attack
here I get mate this is still this is
still a very tricky ending very tricky
yeah now I'm probably just the better
side here because the rooks yeah more
defensive move rook here and then it's a
big race hmm yeah now it's a really big
race if we have the rooks exchanged
who's gonna be faster I don't know
that's a really tough call hmm you know
that's like that's a coin flip
especially with the how much time was
remaining for both of us looked out in
the end there get the pigs on the second
there and in the final position I know
they fell for a million won but King
here how are we looking and we get
pushing you know he's really fast isn't
he and I have really strong rooks mm-hmm
up and down game plenty of mistakes and
this one for sure but I can't have it I
can't have it always clean that's for
sure anyhow feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you